ciao venire se benvenuti novissimo di
ogni giorno migliaia di ragazze si
preparano per uscire affrontando tupi
amletici come metto la eyeliner o no
l'avo i capelli o lilico tacchi o scarpe
basse
ogni giorno migliaia di ragazze
combattono con il loro armadio colpevole
di contenere vestiti che faranno sempre
e comunque schifo
l'unica cosa certa è che non avranno mai
niente da mettere come avrete già
intuito questo video parlerà delle
ragazze quando si preparano per uscire
prima però di partire con la prima
tipologia volevo dirti che mi sono
finalmente iscritta a due di vaughan bot
per chi non lo conoscesse è un socio
dedicato alla moda molto molto carino
dove troverete tante ispirazioni per i
vostri look tutti i nuovi trend ma
soprattutto i miei outfit con i relativi
brand quindi potrete sapere d'olio presi
e potete direttamente acquistarli
dall'app questo il mio profilo correte a
seguirmi la prima tipologia e la
tipologia più comune è la tipologia che
accomuna la maggior parte di noi signore
signore sto parlando della sclerata sé
perché non importa se la serata
l'armadio pieno di vestiti se n'è appena
comprati di nuovi
se deve uscire con le amiche se deve
andare a un appuntamento galante lei
andrà sempre e comunque nel panico più
totale
ma cosa c'è cosa c'è
poi abbiamo la tipologia last minute
last minute è quella ragazza che ha
scelto suo pit e già truccata cretinate
già pronta per uscire ma proprio in quel
momento lei guardandosi allo specchio si
trova piena di difetti e decide
all'ultimo minuto di cambiare totalmente
a tre per prima questa maglia mi fa le
spalle grossissima vorrei darmi una mano
nemica che andrà a cambiare la terza
tipologia è una tipologia che vi
assicuro esiste anche se non vi sembra
davvero
sto parlando del organizzata lo
organizzate quella ragazza che una
settimana prima sa già cosa indosserà
come si bloccherà come si pettinerà quel
determinato giorno però la passeranno a
prendere quanto tempo ci impiegherà
insomma ansia sabato come origins sarà
la fit 1 per un cinema va più che bene
casual e informale per la sera invece da
terol altri due con la giacchetta natoli
tirare i dadi certamente limak holding
titoli a ma con passerà quindi dalle 21
si iniziò a programmi al 19 30 mi
ammazzeranno corona 20 30 minuti alfani
qualche poteva fare a tre socie poi
andiamo là monotematiche a un classico
la monotematica provera tuttora armadio
tutti i vestiti che ha e finirà per
indossare sempre il solito vestito disse
striscio bello è bello però ce li metto
sempre
vabbè dai una volta una volta in meno
passiamo una tipologia che mi auguro non
abbiate tra le vostre amiche sto
parlando di quella ragazza che vi dirà
sto uscendo di casa quando in realtà si
deve ancora fare la doccia truccarsi
passarsi la piastra scegliere l'auto
insomma sto parlando del ritardataria
siamo 5 minuti ed escono siamo auto
uscendo tranquilla sisisi arrivo si amo
lo so è ragione scusa non c'è parcheggia
sto girando da due ore duro adesso la
metà sulle strisce non so più possono
metterla ed ecco a voi una tipologia che
accomuna tutte le ragazze che hanno
delle sorelle me compresa le nostre
sorelle non ce lo perdoneranno mai se lo
ricorderanno per sempre soprattutto se
li abbiamo rovinato ho perso dei vestiti
sto parlando delle saccheggia trici di
armadi mamma io esco
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sì
a questa tipologia di ragazza poco
importa se non sa cosa mettere se la
stanno aspettando 6 probabilmente
neanche uscire di casa
l'unica cosa che la importa e salire sul
suo palco immaginario e cominciare lo
show
grazie grazie questa tipologia l'ho
chiamata maina gioia perché non ho
trovato espressione migliore per
esprimere quel senso di vuoto e di
sconforto che ti prende quando per una
volta che sai cosa mettere non vedo
l'ora di mettere il vestito nuovo
stasera lo sfoggio dalla mamma dove
messo vestito nuovo
l'ometto lavare ma non ero per amare
la rassegnata e colei che apre l'armadio
sapendo già quale sarà il suo destino e
anche stasera esco domani ultima
tipologia super super super comune è la
consulta three ce sto parlando di colei
che non riesce ad uscire di casa senza
essersi prima consultata con tutte le
sue amiche sull'output e su tutti gli
accessori annessi a un'auto cosa ti
metti ma mi sono messa ucciso un top e
anche pensavo così ma pure state basse
però spero non mi metto i tacchi con i
tacchi ma no a motivi che almeno tu nome
di tacche ti prego certo tacchi vestito
come fa chi vestito ma no dai ragazzi ma
mettiamoci d'accordo perché vestito no
purtroppo siamo giunti alla fine di
questo video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto mi raccomando lasciatemi
moonlight e fatemi sapere con un
commento qui sotto quale di queste
tipologie insomma vi rappresenta di più
inoltre se non l'avete ancora fatto
ricordatevi di iscrivervi al canale e di
cliccare sulla campanella vicino al
tasso d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati sul tutti miei video
ricordatevi anche di seguirmi su tutti
gli altri social facebook music hall e
instagram
vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al
prossimo video
[Musica]